Bảo nhân dân, linh qua đến tụ việc thực phẩm bộ xung sữa lua mạnh Ness Play bí lo của công ty chất giảm giữ hạn Ness Play Việt Nam.
Chương nghe mề bốn thằng sấu, công an tình đồng này thông tin đơn vị đã quy định sự phát thành chính và yêu cầu tuổi các sân phẩm quan cảo sai.
Chức đó, công an tình đồng này tiếp dẫn của nguồn tin có giấu hiệu tội phạm luật giới khách hàng.
Sẽ ra tại công ty chất giảm giữ hạn Ness Play Việt Nam, số bẩy đường mề bẩy á, cuối công nghiệp viên hoại hai, thành phố viên hoại.
Sau quá trình đu chả, xa đện hành vi không cầu thành tự phạc.
Giờ đó, ngày 18 thằng sấu, các quan cạnh giác đu chả, công an tình đồng này đã giả quy định sự phát thành chính Ness Play Việt Nam viên viên đưa các thông tin xa lịch.
Không chính xác trên nhắn bảo vì sân phẩm sữa lua mạnh Ness Play bí lo và quan cảo trên các phương tịch thông tin đại chúng ta người nhầm lẫn trong người tư dụng thông qua việc cũng có thông tin xa lịch không đầy đủ, không chính xa.
Cù về đó, khoảng cao có sự dụng các tự nhất, duy nhất, tốt nhất, số một phọc tương nữ có ý nghĩa từng tự mà không có tài liệu hợp pháp trên mình theo quy định.
Căn cứ các hình viên, ngày 18 thằng sấu, đại ta lê mạnh hồ.
Phó giám đốc công an tình đồng này đã khi quy định sự phát bi phạm hành chính đôi với công phí chính giảm hiếu hạn Ness Play Việt Nam về hai hành vi vi phạm nếu trên với tổng số tiền tảm bế trộn.
Đồng thời, trong quy định cũng yêu cầu công phí chính giảm hiếu hạn Ness Play Việt Nam thực hiện nay các mình pháp khóc phục hậu quả.
Bộ ra nghiệp kại chính thông tin xa sự thật hoặc kê giấm lẫn, thao gớm, soa khoảng cao trên các phương tịch.
Hình thức khoảng cao mà công phí đã thực hiện khoảng cao đối với sân phẩm sử lua mạnh Ness Play bi lo có vi phạm về lỗi dung khoảng cao hoặc tuổi sân phẩm báo, tập chiến khoảng cao, nếu có.
Công hãn tình đồng này yêu cầu công phí chính giảm hiếu hạn Ness Play Việt Nam thực hiện các biến pháp khóc phục hậu quả trong thời gian mừng ngày kể từ khi nhận được quy định sự phát tri phạm hành chính.